there was a chill on the scottish
seaside today
matching the bitterness swirling through
this country's politics
where after months of wrangling
allegations of conspiracy and cover-up
a political drama is finally reaching
its climax
the reputation of the scottish
government tainted
the standing of this parliament
diminished
a culture of secrets and cover-up that
is only growing and it is all taking
place
on nicola sturgeon's watch there is a
reputation here that i think is
uh perhaps disintegrating before our
eyes and it's it's not mine
may i say but ruth davidson has just
gone through there
a litany of nonsense
for years they were an almost unbeatable
electoral force
the closest to friends now sworn enemies
leading to division in the party they've
spent their lives building
if there is a conspiracy the
orchestrators of that conspiracy
should be sent packing alex neal serves
in both salmond and sturgeon's cabinets
but for his entire 22 years at hollyrood
one man has been the snp's chief
executive
and he argues the fact that that man is
also nicholas sturgeon's husband
is now a problem if the snp was a
company
then the chances are the board would say
it's not healthy
if the chairman of the company married
to the chief executive
of the company and i think that's
definitely one of the things that comes
out of this that now needs to change
but has this crisis had any impact on
the popularity of the snp
or its leader a new poll out today
suggests support for nicolas surgeon has
slipped by eight
points since october although she still
remains the most popular
scottish party leader by far over a
third of voters say the alex salmond
inquiry has given them
a less favorable opinion of the smp
but the scottish nationalists are still
likely to win may's
holyrood elections now in that election
scots have two votes
one on the constituency ballot and a
second on the regional list and this
poll
suggests that 52 and 47
of those voters will back the smp
respectively
that would give nicola sturgeon 71 msps
in the scottish parliament a majority of
13 she says that would give her a
mandate for a second independence
referendum
even though support for scotland leaving
the uk has slipped slightly
in portobello on scotland's east coast
views on the inquiry are mixed
to me it's a disgrace in the country
that we're at this stage
it feels very unsatisfactory it actually
feels
quite threatening to the sense of
democracy and fairness
i'm very impressed with how nuclear
surgeons have been dealing with the
covert situation that's really what's
important to me at the moment
alex salmond has alleged there was a
conspiracy against him
tomorrow he has to prove it meanwhile
some in the snp worry nicola sturgeon
could be in too deep joe pike sky news
portobello